a este complejo Residencial
característico de la arquitectura en
Ucrania son edificios que rodean estos
pequeños parques aquí cayó en la noche
de ayer al menos dos misiles que mataron
al menos cuatro personas se habla de una
quinta y este hace solamente parte de
uno de los tantos ataques con misiles y
con otro tipo de artillería de las
fuerzas rusas que abandonaron la ciudad
a partir del 11 de noviembre después de
la presión de las fuerzas ucranianas sin
embargo están muy cerca de aquí están al
otro lado del río a un kilómetro y Desde
allí es esto atacan constantemente la
ciudad cada vez más en los últimos días
en el día de hoy ha sido constante y hoy
también volvieron a atacar no muy lejos
de donde nos encontramos en una
plazoleta que es muy céntrica de la
ciudad por allí entran todos los carros
que vienen de ciudades como Nicolás y
también está cerca
complicados y viviendas de residencias
de civiles allí cayeron dos misiles que
mataron otras dos personas y esto ha
llevado a que aumente el temor en la
ciudad muchas más personas decidan
abandonarlas en las últimas horas Porque
temen que estos ataques no solamente
continuarán sino que se pueden hacer
mayores en los próximos días